sur les yvelines on a de très bons
scores puisque on réalise on récolte 42
sièges de conseiller municipal et 11
sièges des conseillers communautaires et
surtout et c'est d'ailleurs grâce à la
mairie de demandes d'asile et qu'ils
étaient donc conquis ce bar sur les
autres et je dois vous dire que monsieur
jean marie le pen est parti vite
particulièrement content que son
candidat est pus va comme un peu le vase
donc et de triste mémoire pour le front
national marine le pen l'a téléphone
elle va annoncer 15 cents par nos
conseillers municipaux
donc c'est cette jument élan 11
septembre on s'y attendait pas c'est
beaucoup et c'est très au delà c'est
très au delà de 2 2 ce qui était attendu